on n'a jamais eu de feedback là dessus
on n'a jamais eu de quelqu'un du
gouvernement qui nous disent on sait
tron s'est trompé en suivant ce papier
ces gens là seront poursuivies ont les
attaquera nous mêmes et je trouve
dommage parce que la suspicion contre le
monde médical et scientifique contre big
pharma elle est née à ce moment là je
m'en dire je n'ai pas de réponse à faire
parce que j'ai pas d'éléments concrets à
vous donner monsieur sur ce sujet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le problème c'est que c'est un péché
originel parce que aucun mea culpa n'a
été fait parce qu'à l'époque le
ministére ans s'est empressée de
communiquer sur la dangerosité du
produit
et puis finalement personne n'est jamais
revenu
[Musique]